so the the subtitle of book why the
rational believe the irrational my point
is that uh people that believe
conspiracy theories are not tin foil hat
uh idiots they're me and you everybody
surveys show everybody believes at least
one conspiracy theory and one reason for
that is my constructive conspiracism a
lot of them are true
so yeah it pays to be a little
constructively paranoid uh just in case
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the publisher of skeptic magazine a
presidential fellow at Chapman
University the host of the Michael
Shermer show and author of the new book
I've got it right here in my hand
conspiracy why the rational believe the
irrational Michael Shermer welcome back
to the Reuben report all right nice to
see you Dave nice to be back good to see
you my friend now before I do anything
else here uh you have one of the largest
stacks of books I've ever seen behind
you is this some kind of Ploy like if
there's uh an earthquake or something
books crash on you clip goes viral it's
very clever and very clever killed by a
conspiracy
by a plethora of conspiracies yes it's
such by your own conspiracy book that
would be odd uh it is good to see you my
friend uh we we did about 30 seconds
before we started recording here but you
have been on this show probably a dozen
times in one car Incarnation or another
um and uh you also have written 400
billion books I I did the math on that
no what what is this speed this is like
16 18 what is it 15th book yeah first
one was first real book uh as as Mr
skeptic was why people believe we're at
things 1997. so I averaged you know like
two a year something like that this
other this conspiracy this is last real
book was 2018 Heaven's on Earth so it
takes me you know three to four years
really on average uh was this was this a
little different I mean a lot your books
obviously they're they're dense and
thoughtful and interesting and one of
the things that I always credit you for
is you you don't pretend you made up
every idea you credit people accordingly
and you call back to people and all
sorts of things but there's a lot of
research in this book you had to dive
into a lot of stuff does that make it
more fun or less fun to write a book
where you're where you're unpacking and
going across all sorts of mediums to
figure out who believes what and why
they believe it I do like to cite uh
authors that actually do the work unlike
some authors who whom I won't name not
you I mean just there's some academics
thank you thank you there's some
academics that are not especially
generous about recognizing where they
got that research there's actually a
huge body of literature on conspiracies
and conspiracy theories why people
believe them sociology of it social
psych cognitive psych you know
anthropology of beliefs and so on
there's a lot in there so I summarize
all that but then try to push the
Frontiers a little bit with some of my
own ideas I constructed a three-part
tripartite you might call it her
three-legged stool of of conspiracism
proxy conspiracism tribal conspiracism
and constructive conspiracism so there's
kind of an overarching theoretical model
that holds together all the different
parts so while most of the details of
course are other people people's
research I've kind of put it all
together in an integrative hole under
that rubric yeah and I really liked how
you did that so as you said there are
sort of three sections to the book a
prologue that leads into it but but then
each one sort of leads into the next one
so I want to get into some of that but
broadly speaking uh one of the questions
I get the most these days if I do a
public event or if I'm doing a q a
online or whatever is people say to me
where do you get your news how do you
know what to believe and I find it's
getting increasingly more difficult to
answer that I you know we're all going
into our little ideological Echo
Chambers I do my best to to not be in
there all the time but it's it's getting
tough for everybody and as I often say
if you're watching MSNBC you basically
live in a different world as the Fox
News person and I think everyone right
now in a modern sense is struggling with
this so the the book for that reason
feels very relevant because I think
everyone's going through some version of
a conspiracy theory to some extent
yeah well so here's one solution I
actually get print newspapers every day
I get the New York Times or say the New
York oh where's my Wall Street Journal
here's my Wall Street okay I got my Wall
Street Journal oh here it is and the
Wall Street Journal there we go so I add
them up and divide by two to get the
truth
division The Wall Street Journal would
be far more factual than the New York
Times which I think has gone really off
the deep end as you know you know Barry
Weiss they were they were so out of
control that Barry White says a liberal
felt she couldn't even stay there
anymore so when you pick up the New York
Times Are you basically going all right
they screwed this one up Ah that's a
deflection this is a confusion
Etc well the Wall Street Journal you
know that separating the opinion section
from the news section uh you know
they're both biased in each direction
that we all know about and that's true
for any of the news sources you might
want to name you have to separate the
like just even Fox News if you just take
the date the daytime news reporters
they're very different from the evening
more like entertainers so I think if you
know what you're looking at but but my
point is you can't rely on any one
source you have to go to multiple
sources including online sources and
just evaluate them and there are sites
that evaluate the biased liberal or
conservative bias of different uh media
sources you just have to do that you
know and NPR I don't trust So Much
Anymore AP Associated Press I I feel is
fairly objective about how they present
things no one's completely unbiased of
course but some multiple sources I mean
and that now there's so many online
really you just have to kind of do a
little bit of your own fact checking and
if you do yeah well isn't that almost
one of the the biggest problems we have
in in this technological adolescence
that we're in that the average person
that even if they want to stay informed
on current events what's going on in the
world the economy whatever it might be
they don't have the time to to go okay
I'm going to read the Times And The Wall
Street Journal and I'll see what they're
saying on Fox and MSNBC and then they
just kind of put their hands up and they
and they check out I think I think we're
getting a lot of that actually
so the the subtitle of the book why the
rational believe the irrational my point
is that uh people that believe
conspiracy theories are not tin foil hat
uh idiots they're me and you everybody
surveys show everybody believes at least
one conspiracy theory and one reason for
that is my constructive conspiracism a
lot of them are true
so yeah it pays to be a little
constructively paranoid uh just in case
but so for most for the most part most
people are rational about their daily
lives you know they they get the kids
off to school they hold jobs you know
they keep the gas in the tank and food
in the fridge and they have a social
life and they're just normal
about things that they could do
something about now if you take some of
the big conspiracy theories like the
rigged election say of 2020. I how would
I check that to know what's going on I
you have to rely on sources that have
the resources and access to check fact
check things like that I wouldn't even
know who to call in Ohio or Georgia or
Arizona to ask you know what about that
truck that pulled up at three in the
morning because that grainy video was
kind of suspicious you know so here we
rely on people that we should trust and
we have traditionally maybe not so much
anymore but for me it uh whatever
questions I had were put to rest when
attorney general Bill Barr said well you
know we had the entire resources the
Department of Justice and we looked into
it and we looked here and we'd text that
and so on and so forth didn't find
anything it's like okay well end of
story as far as I was concerned what do
you say what do you say to the people
that will go well Bill Barr is just part
of the machine that would produce that
sort of lie because that of course as
you know you're the expert in this I
mean conspiracies they jump from one
sort of dead seeming dead end to a new
place and then a new place and a new
place underneath so what do you say well
what I say is well then who who do you
trust what is your Source you know if
you don't trust the entire department of
justice if you don't trust the Trump
appointed attorney general or all the
Trump appointed judges in the cases that
he brought before the courts and so on
uh who would you trust and why would you
trust somebody else if not them I like I
like quoting Christopher Hitchens when
he says which he got from somebody else
which was that if you hear the pope say
he believes in God today you think well
Pope's doing his job again today that's
what he's supposed to do but if you're
the pope say you know I'm beginning to
have some doubts about God's existence
he's like huh he might be odd to
something right so when somebody on your
team or somebody you trust says
something uh that you can pretty much
count on if Bill Barr said hey I you
know I found some suspicion well of
course he's a trump appointing
Republican maybe we need another source
but if he says if he would be motivated
to find fraud and he didn't then I I to
me that UPS the probability that there
was no fraud in the election that's just
kind of how to think about that kind of
conspiracy theory right so since we're
talking about the election and I do
think so much of what we now talk about
related to fake news and this confusion
has to do with the election what would
you say about the the four years that
Trump was president when basically half
of the media or all of the mainstream
media in essence was saying either he
was a Russian plant or that that
election was illegitimate or stolen and
then the second those people were on the
other side now we have Biden as
president they say you can't question
anything and you're going to be booted
off Twitter and YouTube and everywhere
else if you do
that's pretty predictable everybody does
that if you go back in time decades
pretty much every losing side in a
presidential election or even
Congressional races and senatorial races
the the losing side thinks the other
side did something there was some
Shenanigans there was some and then they
usually drop it after a few months and
focus on the next election or whatever
so what's unusual this time is that you
know Trump continues with the conspiracy
theory but that's but let's not blame
Republicans because Democrats do this
also it's pretty common because again
you know there's so it's so complex
there's so many moving Parts in a
national election no one has access to
all the information so you know there's
always going to be some anomalies you
know and then people go anomaly hunting
as we call it and you can always find
them no matter what uh again that blurry
video of the truck that pulled up at
three and what is that you know okay he
had a box okay you know there's always
something like that so we have to so the
part of the problem is the lack of trust
we've always had trust in our systems
that for the most part they work pretty
well and uh yeah so that's but again
like with Trump you know I've been
pretty critical of trump particularly
since the you know that in that last
year but pretty much everything else he
did was pretty standard Republican stuff
you know always lowering taxes he's
helping rich people get richer he's
tightening up the borders foreign policy
and so on it's like that's his job like
the pope that's his job that's what he's
supposed to do you know so it's it's
only when like when George H.W bush said
you know read my lips no new taxes then
he raised taxes like what you're a
republican you're not supposed to do
that right so we have expectations and
Trump you know deregulation of the
economy that was pretty standard
Republican stuff uh and and Biden's
doing what Democrats do right I mean so
you know it's it's not fair to criticize
either one as being extremists when most
of the policies they're doing is pretty
standard
what do you think you since you
mentioned uh trust what do you think we
can do or not we I suppose the the
whatever mainstream institutions that
still exist at this point and it's hard
to tell to what degree they exist
anymore who's watching these things how
much influence they have how could they
gain back trust I I think in most cases
if you were to take say the New York
Times or CNN I don't think there's a way
back now I think they've gone so all in
on so much confusion and been so exposed
as partisan players that I don't know
that they can come back from that and
maybe they shouldn't I don't know uh
well okay so but I'd say Fox News is has
the same problem you know they've kind
of dialed into a business model of you
know ramping up the extremism on their
side uh I don't know you know the Russia
you mentioned you know Russian gate and
all that stuff all those accusations
against Trump you know most of which did
not pan out those were conspiracy
theories you know we think this happened
and it turned out the Mueller report and
so on oh well okay that was kind of a
nothing Burger that doesn't help right
right right right uh so that if you
actually get something it's like yeah
well you cried wolf so many times so
that's not a problem so the the larger
problem I see it is an erosion of trust
across the board scientists used to be
trusted the CDC used to be trusted
teachers professors the academies to be
you know high in uh in trust not anymore
um and so that my last chapter had a
rebuild trust you know that's a hard
problem you know but I sign on with
Jonathan roush's the constitution of
knowledge I think you had Jonathan on
your show uh we've talked briefly once
yeah okay yeah but but this kind of
commitment to like in journalism fact
checking and science peer review
uh in the judicial system you know if
they're a confrontational uh trial
between two attorneys you know to get to
the truth and uh jury of your peers and
so on so there's you know here's kind of
the conservative argument for
maintaining institutions that have been
around for decades or centuries uh and
the reason we keep them is because they
work we've been tweaking them for
centuries the legal system the criminal
justice system
journalism really maybe a century now
they've had you know standards actual
standards fact checking and editors and
things like that you know that that we
rely on that and you know we just have
to keep pushing back that it's just not
cool to make assertions without any
evidence at all yeah you know it's
interesting I'm guessing I think you
either read Well you certainly read it
or maybe wrote a review of it even in
Jordan Peterson's last book in 12 more
rules I think the first of the new set
of rules you know is in essence you got
to be careful when you're burning down
Institution because you don't know what
will come on the other side and I think
that's kind of where we're at right now
we don't trust the old institutions but
we don't know exactly what the new
institutions are yeah exactly well
that's that's classic Berkey and
conservativism Edmund Burke defended the
U.S uh Revolution sorry the the
Revolutionary War but not but not the
French Revolution uh and and he was
right you know because they tore down
everything let's just start over all the
way down to a new calendar system you
know and and new titles and new days of
the week everything's going to be
different and that didn't pan out so
well so and again you know certain
institutions have been around that have
been around for a long time and they've
been tweaked here and there to be more
efficient and fair and just and so on we
should keep that we should not throw
them uh overthrow them too easily and
you mentioned you mentioned science
before and as a man of science and a man
who likes facts uh having been through
two years of covet and you are in
California which I fled because of covid
and and lockdowns and masks and
injections you know mandated injections
all of these things that I felt had
nothing to do with science and I think
in or virtually nothing to do with
science or or a abusive science let's
say
um how how shaky do you think the
scientific world is right now I mean
fauci just in the last couple days
saying oh I was never for lockdowns and
then it's like we're playing videos on
the show where he's calling for
lockdowns yeah a year ago I know
remember what he said when you criticize
me I am the science you're criticizing
experience
yeah so that's it's been a problem for
the reputation of science I guess
because the CDC says one thing and then
changes his mind or fauci says you know
no mass the mass then no Mass but in a
way okay let's just step aside from
particular individuals like fauci and
just say in general if you don't know
what's going on and we didn't you know
you know it was a January 2020 the March
is when we were kind of uh realizing
okay there's something big Happening
Here what is it and it took a long time
to figure out what's the right thing to
do
there's so much uncertainty uh and so
much unpredictability in complex systems
like the human body of you know why do
some people get the virus who double vax
boosted they lead clean healthy lives
you know they're isolated Bast and they
get it anyway and I know people that
didn't do anything they didn't change
their life at all never wore a mask
never got and they get it nothing
happens right so it's like okay because
there's variation you know the body's a
complex system and people respond
differently and so it's these are on
average
recommendations and I try to be
sympathetic by putting myself in
somebody if I was a public policy person
if I was the head of a a Health
Institute or I was the mayor of the city
of La say or governor of California and
they stick a microphone in your face
they go okay what do we do
so here you have kind of a type one type
two error problem signal protection
problem if I say business as usual and
it turns out it's like Ebola or Aids
remember AIDS was a hundred percent
fatal uh at first what if it turns out
like that you know and I really screwed
up and it's on me so they're more likely
to err on the other side like let's
let's uh err on the side of making a
type one error assume it's going to be
terrible and if it isn't well we got
lucky of course they're not calculating
into the equation the effects of
lockdown isolation masks school closes
economic effects and so on which I think
we're years away from knowing what the
full effects so well that will be so far
it looks like it it has damaged our
economy and other things school kids are
behind and social attitudes about
youngsters and how they interact with
each other you know there's some studies
coming out now showing you know these
kids just coming into college now I have
freshmen myself you know they're very
different than they were a few years ago
hard to say what the cause is but social
isolation during covet might be one
anyway those are the kinds wait I'm
curious though how are you how are you
seeing that manifested in your students
now from say five years ago super quiet
very very reticent to say anything there
may be some there may be some cancel
culture effects there you know people
because I bring up abortion like we just
did an issue on abortion so you know
pro-life pro-choice all right kids let's
talk about it and they're you know
they're like uh uh
you know they're afraid to say anything
it's like how can you not have an
opinion uh and you're a Chapman which is
a great defender of research I mean one
of the few universities that is
yeah so here this is reflecting more of
a bottom-up kind of cultural shift I
think maybe they're just shy I don't
know but you know yesterday one of my
student Ted Talks was on uh
attractiveness lookism you know why is
it that good-looking people get more
benefits than others like all right
you've got to have an opinion on this
right here's Brad Pitt that's so unfair
what are we gonna do about Brad Pitt you
know and they're look like looking
around like I don't want to say anything
I'm like oh come on man so it could be
some of that you know we do know there's
a uptick in uh depression and cutting
suicidal ideation particularly among
amongst girls you know is it social
media is it Facebook is it social
isolation during covet you know we
there's different factors we don't know
yet but something there are some effects
to that I'm curious how much of this say
related to kovid was people that maybe
weren't qualified or in some ways were
overqualified to give information giving
information so an example I would use is
right when the the pandemic happened I
had a bunch bunch of experts on people
that are fairly well known and they were
talking about how to wash your bags when
you leave the grocery store and
perfectly you know put your mask on this
way and talking about social distancing
a phrase that no one had really uttered
before and all of these you know all of
these strange things had lockdowns which
really had never been done before at
scale and were based on basically some
wonky paper that never meant anything
but everyone just started saying the
same thing then when we find out it
doesn't work everyone just looks at the
the expert class and goes and I'm not
talking about the fouchies or even the
cdc's I'm just talking about the general
people who are The Taste makers everyone
just looks at them and is like you guys
just screwed us all terribly that's
right right so whenever there's
uncertainty about the cause of something
let's say autism you know one reason
vaccines got associated with autism is
because we don't know the cause of
autism we still don't uh there's
probably multiple causes some genetic
predispositions who knows you know in in
the womb chemistry I don't know you know
we don't know but so that anything
that's even loosely associated then gets
Affiliated as a causal vector and I
think we see a lot of that in pandemics
like this where you just don't know
remember the when AIDS first came online
I mean there was like Panic oh you
shouldn't go in the swimming pool I
remember when Greg Louganis cut his head
on the diving board and Barbara Walters
was doing this private one-on-one
interview with him when he said it
talked about this he's oh my God Greg
you went in the pool right because at
the time it's like oh it could spread
through water with the air don't get on
a bus with an age patient you know it's
a gay disease all this crazy stuff it
was conspiracy theories about it the
black community that the CIA was up to
something uh with AIDS and you know but
these are not completely crazy this is
under my rubric of constructive
conspiracism yeah yeah you know because
the Tuskegee experiments where they you
know withheld treatments to African
Americans with syphilis and other
shenanigans that the CIA and the FBI I
have done to infiltrate black activist
groups to to Blackmail Martin Luther
King Jr and threatened if he doesn't
kill himself they're going to expose
they made sex tapes of him in hotel
rooms with women and so we're going to
play these publicly if you don't kill
yourself this is our government
did this so it's not completely crazy
for people who you know I don't trust
the government it's like yeah okay I
understand
so in essence by the end of reading this
most people will be a little more
libertarian perhaps
whereas you do go into several other
examples of that about how governments
have been doing this oh yes yes right MK
Ultra CA dosing citizen U.S citizens
with LSD just to see what would happen
they actually set up in brothels
um you know they had these Johns coming
and they would dose them with LSD and
then watch film them having sex with
prostitutes let's see what happens here
right it was all under this kind of
larger plan that you know you remember
the missile Gap well this was the the
Mind Control Gap you know the Chinese
and the Russians and the North Koreans
are ahead of us on mind control uh drugs
so we gotta do experiments on this so
again no Congressional approval people
didn't know about it president didn't
even know about it you know this is just
like Rogue uh factions in the in the
security State doing this so when people
talk about the Deep State there's people
behind the scenes doing things well
historically that has happened right
that's just MK Ultra that's just one
this you know this um Counter
Intelligence program this Co Intel Pro
uh it was another you know let's plant
some people in these social justice
groups like the Black Panthers a aim the
American Indian movement feminist groups
and so on and just to make them look bad
or essentially create like a false flag
operation you know let's do it send in
one of our guys they'll do something
really stupid and then then this will
get on the shut on the in the covered in
the media and then they'll look bad I
mean this is like what our our
government does this yeah do you think
it's odd that these things are not
discussed more I mean you go into all of
these things in the book but you know
Fringe internet people talk about these
things guys that run skeptic magazine
talk about these things but you know in
a time where we've watched the
institutions well people would be wise
to be a bit more skeptical about the
information they're being fed yeah you
should be right so I I think of it as a
signal detection problem that is the
signals you're getting in versus the
noise you know is it a real pattern or
is it not that is the pattern you think
is a conspiracy theory that represents a
real conspiracy is that true or not and
so my argument is that well we it's
probably better to err on the side of
being trigger happy like assume it's
real when it's not because that's a less
costly mistake to make than miss the
real conspiracy somebody in your company
is conspiring to hold you down or some
other company is conspiring against your
company or uh you know whatever just
governments do these things all the time
yeah just look at you know what the cas
did in you know rigged election well the
CIA used to try to rig elections in
South American countries to favor
fascist dictators over communist
dictators because they were friendlier
to American business interests in those
countries and you know and again this
was all under the radar no one knew
about it until you know decades later
when it was exposed and uh so that's
that constructive conspiracism you
should it's almost it's almost as if
things might be going on now that we
don't know exactly what's happening I
have no doubt this is the case right and
we won't know for another 20 years
somebody does a Freedom of Information
Act uh you know for your request and
finds out oh my God in 2022 you know
what the CDC or whoever was up to oh
okay no I didn't know that where do you
think uh social media or how do you
think social media plays a part in all
of this you know one of the things just
in terms of the way the internet's
structured that I always think about is
I remember the internet when it started
or you know started on basic AOL or
prodigy or something you go to a website
you get to the bottom of the page and
that was it meaning you could scroll for
a certain period of time then it would
stop then we got infinite scroll so more
and more and more kept coming if you're
on Twitter you can go more and more and
more that Rabbit Hole uh is endless now
and I think a lot of that probably also
feeds a certain part of the brain that
would lead people to some of these ideas
yeah it does uh I mean the history of
conspiracism there's always been
conspiracy theories nothing new there
but but the spread of them in real time
time and the depth that people could go
that I talked about in the book of the
JFK conspiracy theorist you know back in
the 60s and 70s they're just meeting in
little hotel conference rooms with two
dozen people and they had their little
mimeograph newsletters that they mail
out and so not very many people you know
knew about this or were in into it now
you can reach you know millions of
people
instantly in real time and so the spread
is more rapid the you know kind of going
down the rabbit hole the siloing off of
people into these
communities that it's hard to penetrate
um you know that's that's the harder
part is it do you think also easier to
debunk some of these things because of
the speed of information just as fast as
it can spread it can also be debunked
that much more quickly yeah to me that's
the only solution is that because I'm
not in favor of censorship or kicking
people off of social media because they
said the wrong thing this doesn't help
for two reasons one you might be wrong
and that guy that you just kicked off
you might be right no one's
how do you know you know uh John Stuart
Mill you know is it's like if he who
knows only in his own position doesn't
even know that so it's good to listen to
these other people uh but and then
second if you kick somebody off you
cancel culture and so on then Outsiders
observing this will go I wonder if that
guy has something to say and because
they're making such a big deal about it
right banned in Boston oh I want to read
those banned books right
and so you know when someone like uh Joe
Rogan has on Robert Malone to talk about
vaccines and and cardio issues you know
everybody made a big stink about that
it's like well first of all Joe's not 60
minutes where he has to have you know
guests on each side or whatever it's not
what he does you know that going in and
so but if you make a big deal about it
now everyone wants to know well who is
this Robert Malone guy and what is his
argument because no one seems to debunk
it they just say oh it was bad he had
him on well okay what is the problem
somebody should say here's the argument
here's the response and what's what's so
interesting about that is if you
remember so he has Dr Malone on who had
I think if I'm not mistaken more patents
on mRNA technology than anybody I mean
it's not like this guy's a kook right so
he has him on the media goes crazy about
it because he's talking about Ivermectin
and all of these things and then you
remember what happened about four days
later where suddenly we had a week of
Joe Rogan saying the n-word and should
Joe Rogan be de-platformed off Spotify
and everywhere else and that I think led
to LED people to believe you know I
don't even know that this is a
conspiracy theory but that there was
some sort have coordinated attack by the
corporate press on Rogan like he was
becoming too influential so it behooved
CNN to push these oh Joe Rogan's a
racist stories because he's moving in on
their territory I don't know if that's a
conspiracy I mean I don't have all I
don't have the documents from Zucker CNN
but it feels like something that's kind
of there I suspect that's not a top-down
conspiracy like we think of a conspiracy
theory of you know the Illuminati or
somebody power cigarette smoking people
behind closed doors are calling the
shots and the reason I'm skeptical of
most of those theories is because the
world is too complex there's too much
Randomness there's too much chaos from
the bottom up and no one can control it
no one's in control this is part of my
my theory is that it's one thing to be a
a little afraid or anxious about there's
some cabal going on of 12 people called
the Illuminati running the world and
doing a crappy job of it but it's quite
another to think actually nobody's in
control
right there no one can explain the
economy why Wars break I mean I don't
think Putin even knows if he's going to
use tactical nukes or not let alone
Biden or our defense department or I
don't think anybody knows it's just
impossible to know so I view that as is
that scary or more comforting if
nobody's in control I like it because
I'm kind of libertarian in my personal
attitudes and I it's okay with me but
people that prefer a structured
hierarchical worldview that's
predictable that they're not and they
tend to be more conspiratorial in their
thinking a little more paranoid a little
more suspicious that there's things
going on and again things do go on so uh
how do you know well my little test is
you know the more people that have to be
involved in the conspiracy the less
likely the theory is true the more
components that have to come together
just at the right time in the right
place again it's probably not likely if
it if if a lot of things have to happen
because again chance chaos uh
contingency accidents you know people
just don't do what they're supposed to
do you know I remember that when my
first book came out I went on G Gordon
liddy's Radio Show in Washington DC and
why people believe we're things so and I
discussed conspiracies a little bit in
there and he asked me about it and I
said well you're the expert you're Mr
Watergate and he says well actually most
conspiracies are a bunch of baloney
conspiracy theories are because people
can't keep their mouth shut and most
people are incompetent and you know so
this is like 9 11 truth you know the
Bush Administration was in on 911 let it
happen on purpose lie up or made it
happen on purpose my heart well in fact
negative evidence Wikileaks you know
millions of classified documents not one
not one document about 9 11 or we know
they're coming or we're going to let it
happen or you know planting explosive
nothing right so that tells me if if it
was an inside job and these were
classified documents we would predict
that there should be some leakage there
there isn't because most conspiracies we
do find out about them right Lincoln was
assassinated by conspiracy we knew
within hours who did it same thing with
Kennedy I mean Oswald was discovered
within an hour a week they had him at
that theater and so we find out about
these things but not one person wants to
go on record about you know the fake
moon landing where 911 is an inside job
or not one so that's very probably not
true what would you say about something
like the the hunter Biden laptop story
where you know New York Post which is
generally thought of as a reputable news
organization they say this is true they
you know they have their sources Etc big
Tech Twitter particularly comes in you
can't share these stories you can't even
share them through your own private
messaging your own direct messaging on
our platform then other platforms start
doing it as well of course it all turns
out to be legit and there's a lot of
pretty pretty bad stuff on there some
nasty stuff on there I think a lot of
people see that as they see that as a
coordinated conspiracy that that in
essence that thing was going to be
damaging to Joe Biden they wanted Joe
Biden to be president they wanted to be
rid of of trump we accept that big Tech
can just get in on this like does that
is that a conspiracy or is that
Christian yeah that's an interesting
example because here it would be a
conspiracy in the traditional sense if
say the news networks called each other
and said you know I'm I'm not going to
run the story are you going to run the
story I I won't run it if you won't run
it if that was shown that would be a
more traditional definition of a
conspiracy more likely is is more of
kind of a cultural shift or Trend we're
all liberals we want to protect our guy
and so we're just going to bury the
story you know I'm going to do it and
you're going to do it we it's kind of
common knowledge I don't have to call
you up you just know that you know we're
going to kind of work together to
support our guy or criticize the other
guy that's more normal that happens I
think a lot uh without the concerted
top-down you know private phone calls
kind of messaging to coordinate the
effort that would be my suspicion for
that for that that one you know when
when Alex Jones was banned after was he
banned after Sandy Hook or was he banned
after or did you know it was yeah it was
after Sandy Hook for sure yeah well I
know it was after Sandy Hook I don't
remember if that was like the full
impetus for it but whenever he got
banned by everybody within within a day
or so I actually had teal Peter Thiel on
my show the next day and I asked him
privately he has since said it publicly
I said well what do you think happened
here you know did they all coordinate
and he said I think you'll appreciate
this he said actually what he thought
was well you know once one of them did
it once Twitter I think Twitter did it
first then it was just the signal to
everybody else just just go ahead and do
it like now we took the hit we did it so
it's not a coordinated phone call
conspiracy that you're talking about but
it is it's some other level related to
fear and and manipulation and how we all
operate I suppose it's here's an analogy
an athlete gets busted for doping or
some you know horrible thing they did
and Nike drops them and then within an
hour everybody else drops him yeah now I
don't think Nike called any of the other
companies said you got to drop the guy
they all look around and go well we
better go you know what everybody the
big guy's doing and show our support for
or a criticism of this athlete or
whatever it is
what so uh part two of the the way you
lay out the book is how to determine
which conspiracies are real so we're
sort of bouncing around a lot of that in
the in the political sense what about in
just and let's get away from politics
for a second just every other sense
there's aliens and Area 51 and all the
other stuff that we're all how do you
figure out what's real you know somebody
visited you at night and they poke
they're always pronging people and all
that stuff yeah right so some of the
criteria I mentioned already you know
how many people have to be involved uh
how many elements have to come together
just the right uh moment how typical
conspiracies really unfold I went into
detail in that chapter on what triggered
the first world war which was a group of
Serbian nationalists called the black
hand who conspired to assassinate uh
Franz Ferdinand The Heir Apparent of the
austro-hungarian Empire who was leaning
on Serbia to control them and so on so
this was a cabal for sure they met in
secret they plotted for months you know
each of the seven guys had to go to a
certain house and give code word and
then they get the weapon a pistol or a
hand grenade and so on and and you know
one guy didn't he went to the wrong
house another guy chickened out somebody
else you know got the weapon but went to
the wrong place on the parade route
where he was supposed to stand and then
finally some guy actually was able to
pull the pin on the grenade and throw it
but it bounced up the the archduke's
back of his car and rolled under the car
behind him and blew up there and so
these people got hurt oh no and then the
car zooms off and he goes off to his
little meeting gives a speech is thanks
a lot I come here to Sarajevo and you
guys throw bombs at me and then and then
he leaves and then said hey we better go
back to the hospital and check on our
comrade so the driver goes back down the
same road
that they were at and he turns right on
this alpell Quay the main drag there
where the cons the last conspirator this
Gabrielle Principe was sitting there
despondent eating a sandwich from this
Deli and he's got his pistol in his
pocket and he's like well that was a big
[ __ ] up nothing happened and then all of
a sudden here comes the car and the car
makes a wrong turn and there was no
reverse in it so the driver puts it
neutral and just backs up at like one
mile an hour right in front of this
Gabrielle pritch up he's like oh my God
bam dude that's how these things
normally go right you know I mean Nixon
with the with the you know the gmn and
the FBI couldn't even break into the
Democratic hotel at Watergate right
right I mean again if if those guys
can't do it and it by my example that's
how things usually go the more complex
it has to be the less likely the theory
is true 9 11 true impossible I mean
first of all you'd have to have hundreds
of people involved to break through the
drywall of the World Trade Center
building rooms to get into the
structural beams and wrap them in these
explosive devices you know which is how
it's done you know they abandoned
buildings that they demolished they have
to break them apart and put the
explosive devices in there nobody saw
that how did you know oh they operated
under the pretense of being elevator
repairs I mean now you're just hand
waving you know it's just crazy and not
one person wants to go on 60 Minutes and
say I knew somebody I was dating this
guy and he told me all about the 911 oh
my God I gotta have a I have a book out
about you nobody you know has come forth
very very unlikely as opposed to 19
members of al-Qaeda with box cutters see
so so there's kind of a disparate effect
between cause and effect you know the
bigger the effect the bigger the cause
to match it or else we you know just
doesn't feel right so you get you know
JFK killed by who this Lee Harvey Oswald
a lone nut that doesn't feel right so
you had KGB in the FBI and the Russians
and the Cubans and the mafia and now it
feels better or Princess Diana cause of
death drunk driving speeding no seatbelt
tens of thousands of people die like
that every year but princesses are not
supposed to die like that right so it's
got to be the MI6 and the royal family
and Prince Charles and whoever you know
supposed to be in on this and I think
that there's a an effect like that like
there's no way Al-Qaeda could have done
that that's the actually the only way
that could happen to somebody in the
nooks and crannies of a free society
that no one notices that's how you get
away with stuff you know it's funny
because you can also see how through pop
culture some of this stuff leaks in I
mean obviously the movie JFK was
absolutely massive and I'm sure you well
I have no doubt that you don't agree
with the conclusions that Oliver Stone
was putting forth in the movie but even
I was watching the crown on Netflix a
year or so ago and in the last season
where there's a lot about Princess dye
uh you know in essence you're watching
the thing and you're kind of like yeah
it seems like they wanted to kill her
and and you know then she ends up dead
so it just sort of just sits there and
and you can ruminate about all of these
things of course that's hindsight bias
you know every tons of people hated
Obama but he was assassinated so end of
story no one's talking about what what
happened to those people why didn't they
kill him well it's hard to kill a
president right
plenty of people would have been glad to
take out Donald Trump you know Michael
I'm reminded of a couple years ago we've
told the story once or twice publicly
but uh we were at hours I think we're at
Arizona State University if I'm not
mistaken we're doing a talk on free
speech and I at the top of the show I
say to the audience I don't know a
couple hundred kids there I say you know
how many Democrats how many Republicans
how many Libertarians and then I said
how many Nazis just to get a laugh and
if one person stood up in the back and
said that they were a Nazi and I think
you said hey you know if you just wait
to the end we'll we'll take your
question first and that'll be
interesting and let's see what happens
so that we end our our talk and then we
take the question from the Nazi and the
Nazi had all these conspiracy theories
about the Holocaust and the gas Chambers
and all of this stuff I should also
mention it turned out that the Holocaust
denier was also trans which is just sort
of an interesting detail I suppose but
what you did I thought was really
beautiful because you you just flat out
uh explained why the conspiracy theory
was not a conspiracy at all
right and to me that's the way to handle
these kinds of things I mean if you tell
them to shut up or sit down or silence
them or kick them out then onlookers are
going to go well what's the story with
that what what's the problem with that
argument so you gotta at some point you
gotta address the argument which I did
in my book on that and you've been you'd
been to the concentration camps right
you've been to Poland where you can you
explain a little bit about that just
just oh well so yeah Holocaust denial or
revisionism whatever you want to call it
they're they're not saying they're not
claiming that no Jews were were killed
or died there's just downgrading from
six million about a million maybe 500
000. so so it's a clever strategy
because no matter what photos you show
like here's a body stack like hardwood
at this concentration camp how do you
explain that oh that's part of the half
a million I'm willing to admit died of
disease and starvation and overwork and
so on oh okay and uh you know what about
these gas jams oh those were used for
delousing clothing okay well what's the
difference between a delousing chamber
and a homicidal gas chamber there is a
difference but you have to know
something about that right so it does
require some now knowledge like could
you could you explain how why the flat
earthers are wrong could you explain why
creation is so wrong Holocaust deniers
are wrong whatever so you have to so
that's kind of what we specialize in a
skeptic you know what what are the best
arguments the 911 truth there's actually
have and what what's your response how
do uh control demolition buildings fall
do they fall from the top down or the
bottom up it's the bottom up the
opposite of what we saw in the videos
okay so but you have to know that kind
of a little bit of detailed Arcane
knowledge and so I did that with the
Holocaust and and you know it's harder
to prove intention but there's enough
memos from Hitler Himmler get gerbils
and so on that indicate they they after
1941 they intended to exterminate
European jewelry it was not just a
accidental byproduct of the war and um
and then finally that the gas Chambers
were used well there's six death cabs um
here's another trick that the
revisionists use right after the war
they said there were 21 death camps now
they say there's only six the ever
diminishing death camps pretty soon will
be zero no this is how history normally
works right you have the kind of
real-time reporting by journalists and
then the first round of books after an
event or War then the second round and
so on that when you get more information
you change your mind right so okay it's
six and you can go there and you could
you can measure the zyclon blue staining
on the bricks at maidonic for example
and say well that was the chamber where
they killed people it's very different
from the ones where they delouse
clothing and you just kind of go through
all that now when somebody at this point
says I still think the Jews you know are
up to no good all right so now you want
to talk about the Jews and not the
Holocaust right so you have to kind of
bore down to see what the deeper motive
is you know like like with Q Anon or
pizzagate you know there's no possible
way somebody could really believe that
except that one guy Edgar Welch who went
there with a gun to that Comet Ping Pong
so when most people say they believe it
they mean something else like I don't
like Democrats I don't trust that
Hillary you know the clintons are evil I
just you know such that if I took you to
the pizza gate the pizza place and
showed you there's no pedophile ring
here's not even a basement it's not like
you're going to go in that case I'll
vote for Hillary
you were never going to vote for Hillary
so right and I remember after that
incident at Arizona State when when we
were all breaking up I think you started
you continued to talk to the to the
woman and in essence I asked you after
well do you think you convinced her of
anything and and you basically were like
no that's that's not really how it works
because because the deprogramming no
matter how much you offer
in some ways it's almost impossible to
get to that's right sort of what part
three of the book is about that's right
yeah all you're gonna do is plant a seed
it out like how did you get that idea
where did it come from what was the
source what's the quality of the
evidence how do you know that's true
versus some other hypothesis what it
would take to change your mind and so on
it's like cult deprogramming back in the
90s they were you know doing this you
know kidnapping the person from The Cult
and locking them up in a hotel room and
showing them videos or whatever it
didn't work because that's not how it
works you know the people no one joins a
cult they join a group that they think
is a good thing right and then you know
months or years later they're down the
rabbit hole and they didn't even realize
how extreme they got so it's not going
to happen overnight you just have to
plan a little seed like huh interesting
yeah I heard that uh I did wonder though
I have the I call the Colombo thing I
have just one more question you know the
detective Columbus yeah okay just I'm
about to leave but I just thought of
what one thing I was going to ask you
and you have to wear a uh a brown trench
coat when you're doing that or a tan
trench coat turn around and say it right
I'm curious do you have a certain degree
of sympathy as you're writing a book
like this a certain degree of Sympathy
for the people that fall into these
traps because you know if you look again
if we bring it back to the news if you
look at the the way the mainstream media
for a year said that Brett Kavanaugh is
a serial rapist turned out not to be
true Kyle Rittenhouse is a white
supremacist turned out not to be true uh
Jesse Smollett was going to be lynched
or got attacked by those two guys turns
out he hired them uh Donald Trump very
fine people on both sides yes the
sentence after was um you know I I
completely condemn white supremacists
all of these things that lead I think a
certain set of good people to perhaps
come to wrong conclusions but I actually
I'm not even going to say that always I
think in some ways they then come to the
right conclusion but I but I always say
I have sympathy for the people that are
just like yeah these people are lying to
us about so much what else do you expect
from us yeah exactly so that's why the
you know journalism has to stick to this
strict ethic of fact checking and double
fact checking and multiple sources and
so on and they don't do that if if it
fits a particular Narrative of course
we're highlighting the the big stories
that got wrong most of the stories they
get right that are not that big or
important uh we you know kind of fly
under the radar we don't notice those
most journalists most of the time are
just doing their job uh it's the big
ones that stand out and it's in
particular if it fits a narrative of
your department then you probably should
ask for another source or maybe let's
wait a day but you know the the economic
model is you can't wait a day right we
got to get this out before the other
blogger gets it out of the other network
right so
um yeah and again you know you you
toggle between the three major networks
on the news every night which I do uh it
seems like there's a script they all the
same stories is like the same order and
I'm I'm pretty sure they don't call each
other go well okay I'm gonna cover this
one first which you know which order are
you gonna put it it's just how the the
system works and I just you know I wish
it was different or you know there was
just more subtlety or more I don't know
caution skepticism
Michael can you stick around for a one
more thing for my locals Community I
wanna I wanna specifically ask you about
my favorite conspiracy theory we'll do
that on locals uh but the book is
conspiracy why the rational believe the
irrational and uh we'll link to it right
down below if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about Academia instead of non-stop
yelling check out our Academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification Bell